hello everyone
i would like to welcome you all for
today's free webinar
which is about a special opportunity to
learn modern biotechnology
and life science techniques using
innovative or mixed logic research based
online training
my name is sunalika ray and i want to
start by introducing our company
vision and team that stands behind the
various resources
and training programs we will go over
today
omixlogic is a program for
bioinformatics training that was
developed in collaboration between pine
biotech
and the toba bioinformatics research
center at the university of haifa
the company was started as a result of
technology transfer from the center
which was founded by dr alfred trauber
and dr lunit brodsky dr alfred tober who
comes from a medical background has
extensive expertise in oncology
immunology and biochemistry of
information
and has been recognized internationally
for his generous support
of many research projects and
initiatives that support data science
training
and applications in medicine
dr leonid brodsky is the director of the
toba bioinformatics resource center
at the university of haifa and is an
expert in bioinformatics and
biostatistics
he has numerous publications in
mathematics and bioinformatics
and over the course of his career he has
developed multiple novel algorithmic
approaches to biomedical data analysis
the rest of the team includes experts in
bioinformatics
computer science and training some of
our team members will be presenting
today as well
as a result we have acquired
professional certification
to offer our curriculum and support
research projects using our omics logic
program project-based curriculum
over the past several years we had the
privilege of working with a number of
organizations developing a training
program
for research-oriented students faculty
and democratizing
bioinformatics making this discipline
accessible
to thousands of students and faculty
around the world
using the cutting edge omixlogic
resources we bring a unique opportunity
to learn computational biology and apply
data science techniques by working with
experts bioinformaticians and in today's
webinar we will go through the
introduction to the program
followed by an overview of basics of
bioinformatics and big data
concepts and applications genomic
medicine
and sequencing data analysis in
biomedical research
application of microbiome and
metagenomics
analysis in life sciences and
transcriptomics data analysis and its
application in the machine learning
before we go through the topics that
will be covered in the program
as a community manager i interact with
participants who are interested to know
if they are eligible for the training
program let me explain that
so this program is a great fit for
students who are interested in learning
about the ongoing life science research
and to develop skill sets to analyze
genetic and clinical data
this program is also a great fit for
researchers who are keen to apply
computational biology tools
to their research projects and faculty
while working on the research projects
and proposals and have a keen interest
in the in teaching bioinformatics
the industry driven omics logic
curriculum helps biologists and
clinicians working with
industry and research labs to analyze
their own data
and take decisions based on the analysis
this program is available through our
collaborators and
mentors in the u.s canada india sri
lanka and for the students and
researchers in africa
as well now to talk more about our mixed
logic bioinformatics training and
computational biology program
i would like to invite dr mohit mazumdar
who has a phd in computational biology
university and is an author of more than
30 international publications
on bioinformatics research over to you
dr bhumit
thank you sunalika
thank you sonalika for the introduction
hello everyone
uh we are absolutely delighted to have
you all today for this webinar
on computational biology program for
everyone joining for the first time
my name is mohit mazumdar and i am a
bioinformatician by education
and since last 12 years i've been
practicing
and applying bioinformatics for research
and now
for both research uh training and
collaborations
to all the participants who have joined
us today it would be really nice
uh to know your background educational
background too and i saw that many of
you have
already shared with us so nice to know
um
about your research interest about your
educational background so that
we can understand and uh guide you
better
so if you are from life science then you
must have studied biotechnology right
so biotechnology has been in use since
1919
so it's a long time back and uh it has
uh its first application was in dna
recombination experiments with bacteria
right and today biotechnology in itself
has been applied in manufacturing of
medicines
medicinal devices diagnostic tools uh
bio
bio materials food technology and food
production
all of that but today we wanted to talk
to you about another exciting field
which is computational biology so
computational biology
which is a relatively new field of uh
research
has been evolving at an exponential
phase and
it's such an exciting field of biology
and
we will learn more about it in today's
session
uh and to talk a little bit about uh
computational biology there's a reason
that this
exponential pace that
it has got it is because of the enormous
amount enormous amount of
biological data that has accumulated
over the years
and the size of this data is uh ever
growing
and the application of biology in life
in itself
is growing uh already and it has been
shown
even for the experiment that uh some
scientists did
a few a few days a few months ago that
dna can be used to store
uh data just like our typical hard
drives right
scientists were able to show that 700
terabytes of uh
data could be stored in a single you
know single gram of dna
so that's like pretty exciting right so
but our objective here is to
simplify complex bioinformatics methods
that have been applied in these
amazing experiments and then
we want also want to use these methods
effectively and efficiently to tackle
unsolved problems in biology and in
healthcare
so uh i would also like to tell you
about in much more detail about the
omics logic program
but before i do that i would like to ask
uh
if any one of you would like to have a
discussion a question please feel free
to put it in the chat
chat option so that we can go through
this later
and answer your questions so uh going
back to the presentation and about the
homicide programs and what we've been
doing and been talking about
so the goal of homicide program is to
provide training in bioinformatics
enabling independent research guided by
mentors and peer examples
another aspect of important aspect of
omics logic program is to develop a
growing community with a shared passion
for data driven research
and application of citizen scientist
science projects
so we have a growing community of over
10 000 people who are computational
biologists
researchers biologists clinicians
who interact with each other and enrich
this information
sharing and collaboration the third
objective is to enable students
and clinicians and faculty of all
background people who are interested
genuinely
would want to learn more about it apply
these skill sets
in their research areas in for job
opportunities
and to develop noble and independent
research using
uh life science are the latest uh
technologies
in in bioinformatics and computational
biology so these are some of the
objectives that we
uh that we wanted to tell you all about
and the next thing uh is about the
program itself because
we would want to you know complete some
of these objectives by going through a
training method
so this online program is designed for
everyone
including students who don't have a
background in bioinformatics
so the topics covered in this program uh
enables anyone to learn the
ngs data analysis because we will be
going through
different kind of processing sections
but
for doing different sort of analysis
such as genomic analysis
and i've heard many of you are
interested in transcriptomic analysis
and interpreting the omics data using
machine learning techniques
so we will learn about also along with
this we will also
be learning about public repositories
where various file formats are being you
know deposited
by different laboratories and companies
and their application and then
understanding their application for
biological research
so this analysis will include we will be
doing annotation
visualization and interpretation of the
results
so uh before we go into those technology
um let me start today by mentioning that
as a company in this space we are
focused
on addressing some of the pressing needs
in biotechnology
and in clinical market by providing user
friendly tools for researchers
clinicians students to leverage this
transformational opportunity of our
lifetimes
because this is where the uh where the
innovation is coming this is where the
latest technology is heading to us today
we will be learning about the overview
of topics as
uh as promised that will be covered in
the program so let's start discussing
about the basics of bioinformatics
big data and this concepts and
applications
so in in bioinformatics
um if we talk about big data so the
biological experiments produce
magnitude of multitudes of data today so
compared to 20 years ago so before that
we were using single experiments to
generate data now there are
thousands of experiments automated
experiments that are generating this
multitude of data and then we have open
source data
databases like ncbi uh scientists from
different part of the world
can share their data and can collaborate
with ease
so that's the new world and we have now
crossed the
excel barrier as well so earlier we were
used to
use i mean most of the time we even use
excel
ms excel for uh for uh you know
collaborating and sharing data so
bioinformatics researchers
who are now are adapt with
statistics data and programming on top
of
domain knowledge there are also demands
such as you know
learning tools such as panda nymphy uh
matplot r shiny
all of that that actually efficiently
help us to you know
maybe use machine learning as well so
this
is uh right now is the market in
bioinformatics
and there's a huge opportunity
associated with it or
also because it's a growing market and
uh
it has a lot of demand for
all the biomedical research that is
ongoing disease related research
and many more application that today we
will discuss
so learning about this i mean what is
the gap
where we are i mean what is lacking and
what we can do
so breakthroughs in molecular biology
advances of precision medicine
biotechnology and agriculture have
translated into
advanced technologies right because now
we are generating data
with ease and that simplified generation
of
accurate and in-depth data is
is something like a blessing in a way
but at the same time it poses
like a lot of questions because
there's a lack of analytical power and
appropriate skills that creates like a
huge gap
because we have high quality data now
but we need
experts to understand the data and make
sense of that data
so those expertise and skill sets are
lacking
and many of uh because of this there's
this gap
between data and information in this in
this field of computational biology
and bioinformatics and from a standpoint
of what has been
seen as so bioinformaticians as such
were viewed more like you know computer
scientists before
who could manage a database maybe run
some algorithms but modern
bioinformaticians
are different and i'm telling you i'm
going to tell you why
because modern bioinformaticians have to
identify
what questions what questions a
researcher
should ask how to look for um
right answers that's a very important
part
and then how to what to do with this
large data
large amount of data produced from these
studies that is also a job of a
bioinformatician to learn and understand
and also for all those people who are in
the pa
who are in biology and are now
progressing towards
learning more about biology and its
application
so in bioinformatics uh
now as i was telling you about the
opportunities
these scientists who are being able to
do all of this
who can ask the research question find
data set
understand what answer that data set can
give
these scientists are now integrated into
every research
team making them into the core of
innovation so it's very important
and these uh so biology
and as a field has been now ushering
with the age of
ai big data with it and creating a new
line of scientists that's where i'm
coming at
which is bioinformaticians and
computational biologists
so now about uh bioinformatics
and the different kind of challenges
so when we talk about you know technical
demand that prevents us from learning
these skill sets
because of the computational power that
is sometimes required
for us to do all this analysis so in
most of the cases that
that means that you know our ability to
analyze data
and extract meaningful meaningful
information
is lagging behind because of the pace at
which
the new new data is being generated so
oftentimes like clinician
biologists students from life science
background report about
challenges with data analysis and
interpretation that is holding them back
and limiting their ability to rely on
advanced technologies such as genomes
genomic sequencing
which we could incorporate in our
studies in our research
and that could actually give us a really
bright clear picture of what what is
going on
so uh if i talk about bioinformatics and
computational biology the first three
words
that you know wikipedia used to describe
bioinformatics
are um is an it is an interdisciplinary
field
so when we talk think about these three
broad fields
for example biology statistics computer
science
or you can say instead of statistics
data science
but what exactly these disciplines uh
are
and are there other fields within this
these disciplines
so when it comes to application in the
context of biology
the current realm of molecular biology
in the current realm of biology includes
molecular biology
genetics genomics proteomics
metabolomics systematic
evolution evolution uh pharmacology
biomedicine
healthcare uh healthcare health sciences
and
and the list goes on so this is not an
exist exhaustive list but
when it comes to computer science there
are there are like obvious ones
like uh software engineering database
management
uh information uh information
engineering
natural language processing image
processing so these are
some of the fields uh that are
associated with the interdisciplinary
nature of
uh bioinformatics or computational
biology and how we can
now being being able to utilize these
different areas
of uh you know these different
technologies into
one area of biology so so what is
bioinformatics i think it's a
convergence of biology and data
where both are equally important
so um we've been talking about data
so let's understand some of the data
types which are like some of the genetic
data types
omix data types so omix data includes
phenomics genomics
[Music]
epigenomics technologies and that can be
used to
these technologies are uh are so
important in today's world because they
can be used to explore the roles
relationships actions of various types
of molecules
that makes up our cell that makes up a
cell of an organism
so many of this omics data can be
generated using the ngs technology which
is
uh commonly also known as high
throughput sequencing
and this data shows as i was telling you
before this data shows detailed
information
about genomic variants pattern of gene
isoform expression and for an entire
organism
and for the entire uh time point so
the application of this technolo these
technologies is something that is really
exciting and
that we will be learning about in the
next few in the next
few slides so one particularly
uh exciting area of bio bioinformatics
uh
is its use in precision and personalized
medicine i think many of you have heard
about it
so what what is happening is doctors are
learning more and more about the
influences of the gene on a person's
physiology
as a person's metabolism and more
importantly how drugs
interact with their exact phenotypes so
these are some of the things
other than that using per patient's
personal
uh genetic makeup and comparing it with
the database of thousands of other
patients
doctors can make more informed decisions
about treatment
and therapeutic choices so these are
some of the possibilities that are
already
happening in many places some of the
drugs may be more efficient for a
patient than others
while some of the drugs may may have
more unwanted side effects
uh for some other patients all all these
could be
you know theoretically can be evaluated
now
given the hospital heaven i mean maybe
hospital
or the organization have an access to
those uh databases and then they have
the expertise
to compare and find uh similar genotypes
that could be treated with similar drugs
so there are
different uh applications in medical
sciences
that that could help make the entire
healthcare system or the medical science
more robust empirical and casual than
uh correlational and or uncertain
right so most of such data types are
generated randomly
at a high speed these sort of data sets
are
generated at a really high speed and
these require
like com complex computational data
processing system
a procedure to generate structured data
sets
which can be visualized and analyzed uh
statistically so that is some of the
challenges
that are associated with such high
throughput data
but i mean this is a program that where
we would want to simplify that
and take you through this entire process
of how we can
actually do this uh by
learning the logic
now um this about this training program
so in this first
training program we will have live
sessions uh
fpv and the first live session will be
about orientation
and introduction to omix logic
coursework and access to the
multiomics user-friendly tbi info
platform
so after the program registration and
many of you might have already
registered
for the program the first week
uh we will have participants uh and we
will have orientation under introduction
section
uh session in this session we will be
collaboratively working with students
to complete their academic uh profile on
learn omis logic
and set up accounts on big data
analytical uh t-band for platform
so uh about this i mean anyone
anyone can join the omixlogic
bioinformatics community
for free and and that will we will be
showing you
in a while uh so in this week we will
also learn about big data
application of bioinformatics and uh
after we do the sign up which we will be
doing in the next uh
next few slides i'll be taking you
through the hands-on
courses and the premium courses
associated with
each week for you to learn all of this
on your own
so in the next session after the first
orientation
session and the introduction session
where we get to learn
about you about your interest about the
area
that you would want to work on maybe if
not about the basic
training the help that you need to go to
the next level
so in the next session we will be
learning about this various
ngs technologies and ngs technologies
starting with genomics we will learn to
we will learn to analyze ngs genomic
data
and to give you an overview genomics
isn't
is an essential essential sub subfield
of bioinformatics
and is a major force in expanding human
knowledge for genetically associated
associations with disease and other
traits it's an interdisciplinary field
again
and it includes development of methods
for dna sequencing
as well as big data analysis for genomic
sequences so ngs data or
ngs techniques allow whole genome
sequencing
and then analysis of epigenetic factors
uh for
as epigenomics for dna protein
interaction
dna methylation with i mean it is very
efficient and which has very efficient
way to identify those and there are
massive databases obviously i talked
about ncbi
there's gene bank embl sra for uh
for you to do data driven discovery and
knowledge discovery
so this session uh serves an as an
introduction
to the field sub disciplinary field of
genomics
participants will get familiarized with
biology of genetics genetic variation
and other uh practical applications
and to tell you i mean i will be telling
you more about this
uh entire week uh once we go once you
all
uh are signed up so that we can have a
like a demonstration
of what will be covered so in the next
session after learning about
genomics uh we will learn about
metagenomics or you will have an
opportunity to learn about
metagenomics so this is
a one month program and i would want to
clarify
that we will have you will have a lot of
resources
that you can you know complete in that
period or you can
extend uh keep on extending and keep on
learning
about different data types so yeah
obviously
there is an opportunity to do this right
now in a month's time but i mean
many of you would want to go and deep
dive and keep
can do uh these analysis uh after
subscribing for the program
every month so in this session we will
learn about application of microbiome
metagenomic analysis and life sciences
and as as you know metagenomics is to
study
a collection of genetic materials or
genomes from a mixed community of
organisms
metagenomics is usually refers to study
of microbial community
and we have also
different projects in metagenomics to
explain
different sort of analysis that i'll
take you through after the login
so in after the metagenomics section
uh we will move to another section of
analysis which is transcriptomics
analysis this is like high throughput
gene expression data analysis
so in this session we will be uh doing
the analysis
using omics logic resources and the t
bio info platform
that we will be talking to you about uh
very soon
in the session so transcriptomics to
give you an overview is
to study uh organisms transcriptome
the transcriptome refers as a sum of an
organism
uh organisms rna transcript right so
the dna information that is there in the
genome
gets converted into rna through a
process called transcription
a segment of dna that gets transcribed
into uh
into an rna molecule is called the
transcriptom
transcript unit so studying and
understanding the transcriptome
gene expression expression levels help
us understand that
what are the proteins or what are the
you know key genes
that were maybe expressed differently in
a
different condition so it is also about
comparing comparing
these uh different uh expression
profiles that we get from different
experiments
and uh that technology and will be
also covered like com doing differential
gene expression
how would you do that how can you uh get
from raw data to a structured table of
expression first of all
and uh identify which are the important
genes that have shown this variation by
using different type of statistical
analysis
so we will be learning we will be
learning and we will also learn to use
this various statistical
methods of data analysis using
supervised and unsupervised machine
learning
that can be applied to biomedical data
or different kind of other data types
so using various examples of omics data
we will see
how such analysis can yield significant
results
for various biomedical applications and
it's i quoted this because it's very
important because
when you are looking uh in for
information from a very big data
it's like finding needle from the
haystack so
significant uh result is something that
is
uh very important and could be you know
if it is a research it could be
publishable as well
so um about the omixlogic program
in this omixlogic beginners training
program
the participants will have an
opportunity to learn about various
technologies
uh tools algorithms and pipelines and
workflows and data sets and research
publications
and these are some of the six data types
that you can see on the slide
so together with this existing module
modules
for which you will gain access for the
omixlogic learn portal
where you can explore these modules uh
exercise the pipeline building
how can you build a pipeline how can you
do uh coding from the very basic
and apply it for bioinformatics not
hardcore
programming and various methods of
analysis
using project uh examples from peer
reviewed
peer-reviewed publication but to start
with this i mean
uh we will have to do uh the login or
the sign up together
so uh now let me invite uh sunalika
now again uh community manager to help
us
create a login show us all how to create
a login
and then we will start exploring these
resources that i just discussed
thank you so much dr mohamed now i would
request you
all to go to our portal that is learn
dot omics logic am sharing the link with
you all in the chat box
it would be great if you could follow
along
now once you are on the portal you need
to login
if you have not created an account yet
then you need to
sign up those who have signed up already
uh please let me know in the chat box by
sending a yes or
one maybe and those who have not yet
signed up
you can go along here is the link with
you for you all
in the chat box and
you have two options to sign up it would
be great if you could create an account
for yourself
with your mail id and create a password
as well
or you can also login with your social
account
let me know in the chat box if you're
going along
thank you what about others have you
logged in
let's wait for five minutes maybe
or two to three minutes for you all to
log in please let me know in the chat
box i'm waiting for you all to log in
thank you priyanka thank you ruby
thank you sonya
for those who have logged in let me just
tell you how you have to
begin with so to begin with first of all
you have to update your profile
picture and also link in your social
account
and ensure that you have your name in
the correct format
it should be title case and not in
capitals or not in small
because this is the name that would be
reflected on your certificates
yes madhumita i can wait for you thank
you chica
those who have already updated their
profile it's good others can update
their profiles
uh in between the session or later as
well
and you can see all your activity in the
profile tab so let's say you started
with the course on genomics or let's say
bytes and molecules
you can see how many lessons you have
covered
and how many are still to go and once
you have
covered or completed all the sessions
you would be able to get the certificate
in the in the certificates tab in your
profile section itself
and after joining the program on the
omixlogic bioinformatics and
computational biology
you would be able to see the program
under your profile and as the program
has not started yet that's where it
shows zero out of four so once the
program would begin
i would be posting in all the recordings
for the program on the program
page and you would have to complete the
sessions to get the certificate
on the program page we have mentioned
about what all would be included in the
program so we have four workshops in
total and dr
mohit would be explaining about each and
every workshop in detail
and i would be uploading the recording
of each and every workshop once it's
over
and also you would be able to find the
schedule for the program
so i had a message in the chat box
where the participant was asking about
the schedule so we have four
sessions scheduled on uh second august
fifth august ninth august and twelfth
august and also you would be guided
towards the asynchronous course material
have you all signed up please let me
know in the chat box
sorry
while others are signing up i would just
want to quickly launch a poll
to know about you all in a more better
way
my first question is what is your
educational background
are you an undergraduate graduate post
graduate
phd or a postdoc
and my second question is what is your
current position
are you a student researcher faculty
or are you from management and
administration
and my third question is what are your
research interests
is it infectious diseases genomics
transcriptomics
metagenomics data science machine
learning
or bioinformatics using r or python
the poll would be up for a minute thank
you for
giving out your votes
i can see 40 people uh have
already voted i would request others to
vote as well
uh yoke you have to go to the profile
section
and update your profile
after your after you are done with
signing up on the portal
and we will be sharing the program page
link with you
all for you to register
thank you zanalika if i may take over
now yes
over to you sir thank you
i'm ending the poll i hope everyone uh
has voted
what are you dr mohammed okay thank you
sonalika
and uh if you can see my screen
yes sir we can see your screen
sorry
so let us go to the omix logic learn and
i have logged in
i have a profile here as uh sanatika
showed all of us
that you can create your profile and you
can have a picture
uh and you can have your name and social
media links if you like
you will see the courses that you
complete and
the achievements that you did the you
will also accumulate points for your
achievements
so i've accumulated almost 5 000 points
and i've gained two certificates so far
so you can keep on doing the courses
and gain a lot of certifications for the
courses itself
and the for program if you're joining
the program
you can also you will also be eligible
to get a program certificate
now uh going back to some of the
questions whether this program is a paid
program
how do you access the resources that we
discussed how to go about the training
and what are the next steps
these are something that i am going to
tell you about in much more detail now
so uh in omixlogic community as i said
it's a free community anyone can join
for free here you can see register for
free
but uh there are premium courses which
requires you to utilize the
uh t-band for servers so there's a
subscription for the program a minimal
a very minimal cost that we have kept
together and that's why we are calling
it a special
opportunity for you to learn from us and
learn from the resources that are
available
so you can join the program to access
the premium courses otherwise you will
have access to the free courses
i will tell you which free courses and
how you can access those as well once
you have created a login
i'll do that but before that i mean if
you are interested
in going through the entire you know
sessions going through the workshops by
experts
uh going through the premium courses and
all of that then you
have to join the program uh through this
page
and it's kind of simple so let me
show you i'm already a part of the
program so
if i have to join the program how can i
join you obviously you'll have to
log in from your account first and then
you will see the program page and
once you go in this program page
or if you can also like go to the link
directly you will be able to come to
this program page
and then you will have to complete your
registration
so you can give your information and
you we will be sending you more
information about the program more
details if you are
not sure about what will be covered and
at the same time you can start your
application and you book your seat
so it's a program that will be available
for anyone to take
and you can join this entire whatever we
covered in today's session will be
available with the beginners license so
we have different subscription levels
so the first beginner subscription level
is just for ten dollars a month which
will give you access to all of the
things that we discussed today
and we have different other subscription
levels for you to do research
for you to do work on project and uh
maybe we will discuss it in the next
time when we meet
but for this program you will be able to
do all the course work and all the live
sessions that we just
discussed and about the course work i'm
going to tell you
what all coursework are there which are
for free and which are for premium and
why they are premium
and why there is a cost so let me go
back to the slide deck
yeah the first course that we have put
together for everyone to take
is a free course uh other than the ones
that you've seen star other premium ones
so uh when you do this course and go
through this course bytes and molecule
you get an
overview of a very basic understanding
about the different data types that we
will be discussing
in the program so anyone coming from a
background
without a knowledge of biology can start
taking this
course bytes and molecules so let me
just quickly show you a video
for the same
bites and molecules
every living cell has its own hard drive
where it stores bites
of information needed to function and
grow adapt to environmental changes
and fight off dangerous intruders this
information is stored in molecules that
are arranged in sequences of letters
referred to as dna code in the 1990s a
tremendous effort by governments
researchers
and companies resulted in the full
sequence of the human
genome since then we've seen an
exponential growth of molecular data
that describes
cells tissue organs and organisms
massive data sets containing genetic
information about the young
old healthy and sick are now freely
available to the public
here we will explore the various omics
data types as well as examples of the
information they contain
genomic variants associated with
ancestry gene
expression levels responsible for cancer
spread and
protein modifications that can render
important code unreadable
this course is intended for all those
interested in understanding how the
current revolution in biomedical data
impacts biomedical research and human
health
so as you learn from this this is the
first course that you will go through
and it's a free course anyone can take
and in this course you will learn about
the different data types
another free course that we have is the
introduction to bioinformatics
uh it's a course that takes you through
different types of uh you know
application of bioinformatics
big data bioinformatics as i said and
it's a course where we get to learn
about you
your uh expectations what do you want to
learn in bioinformatics
which area of research that you are
interested in so this course has a form
when you start this taking this course
uh you will get a form and i'll request
to sonalika to share maybe the
link to this course as well so this is
an introductory course where you will
get
the overview of different type of
fields uh where you can apply
bioinformatics and you can also tell us
about
your uh area of research where you are
interested in
so these two courses uh is something
that you
we would want you to start with uh even
if you are joining
the program even if you're not joining
the program it will be
really helpful for you to go through
these courses so
once you go through these courses uh we
also have
other free courses introductory courses
for r for omics bioinformatics as i said
that in this program you will also have
opportunity to learn coding
you will have also uh have an
opportunity to
learn uh this from the browser itself
and get points and recognition and all
of that
by while completing this coursework so
in the
this first tutorial which is just to get
started with bioinformatics
it tells you about you know loading
structural data into our
a multi-dimensional data visualization
in our
readings a very uh basic uh file
uh dna file uh and then understanding
the dna replication and reverse
complement
complements in r so this is if
uh here also you will have free courses
where you can learn about these
different technologies
uh and how it can be applied different
programming languages
how it can be applied for data
visualization now
i mean i told you about the premium
courses as well
so the premium courses how they can help
you do
the hands-on analysis on on yourself by
yourself
at your own pace so let's take a look at
that let's have a demonstration about
that as well
so let's go to the learn portal again
and
now what we will do is that we will go
to the section called
courses and we will find all the courses
that we are interested in
if you are interested in python we can
try python if you are interested in
r we can do r if you are learning one
want to learn about the introduction to
bioinformatics and genomics
and then epigenomics then all of this
course material
is here we will just have to search for
them
and and i'll show you
that's pretty simple
okay i'll have to log in first
so i'm logged in now i can see the
courses
so let's take a look at the our course
so we have different courses as i said
getting started with our
another course is introduction to data
science
using our now we have a lot of lessons
within these courses
that you can take and earn points from
so let me show you how it works
and how it is so simple and easy to do
this that anyone can learn from this
because when you start from you know
basic
you tend to get an understanding of
what's going on and you understand
different type of
uh different type of commands that are
being used and get familiarized with it
so we start with uh you know
you can install r locally on your
computer as well
and try this out and you can do this
from the browser itself
as well so with every tutorial that you
see here
the first part is the about is to
understand the problem what the problem
is all about
what we are doing here so we are doing
we are looking at different type of uh
data categorical data or continuous data
in data science and then
we are trying to do some plotting to see
the characteristics of data
i mean how they are uh placed if we can
you know separate them or not so this is
being used in many
of the bioinformatics application in
many bioinformatics applications
especially when we are doing big data
analysis so here i mean
you will learn to upload the data how
you can use links
and uh upload the data into the
into the into the browser and then
you can run different sort of commands
to analyze that data so once we learn
about these different commands which is
just shown here
you can go through them and easily learn
about them
then there is a breakdown of code that
will be used for
this tutorial so what this code is doing
so it actually explains all of it and
what kind of results that we can expect
and what kind of analysis that we can do
from this sort of data so once you do
this uh
you get to a point that where you can
practice it yourself so it's a
code playground where you can write your
own code and
you can load data and you can run the
analysis here itself
to show that if if you're getting the
result or not as you see
as as you like as you can see that this
is already a
code that is uh put together and is
working you can change this
and you can run your own code and do
your own analysis downstream analysis
using this code
uh code blocks uh and different
tutorials that have been shown here
uh that have been shown here in the
learn portal that you will have access
to so
uh the opportunity is there is a lot of
opportunity to learn about different
things
so i just told you about uh this r code
now let me go back to the uh to the
slides
and i'll show you what all different
courses that we have put together for
you to take so uh you can start from
python as well similar courses
you can apply and see what is the
difference how you can learn both of
them
and uh i mean choose what you are i mean
more comfortable in and what kind of
analysis that you are
into and what kind of research that
requires
to use these uh languages
and apply these languages for data
analysis
so another thing another important
aspect of this
this sort of learning omics logic
bioinformatics training
is to be able to access the tbi info
platform
and run your own analysis and get the
structured data to analyze further in
r and python so when we go through
uh these courses uh such as genomics
as i said in the second session after
the introduction session we will be
doing
genomics so in genomics we will be going
through
very basic starts from the dna structure
and variants why we are
using the genomic technology genomics
technology
and where it has been helped helpful how
we can identify variants
and identify mutations that are critical
uh learning about that working using art
then introduction to genomics
where you get an overview of all of that
in much more detail in depth
and then practicing using the pipelines
as i was telling you that
you will be getting an overview and
understanding of
how by how algorithms are connected
together
and they give us a result
a structured result after doing a
complete analysis
so there are several tutorials and the
ones that are starred
uh includes practical uh assignments
so for that you will be able to access
the tbi
info server to uh to run some example
pipelines and now let me take you to the
t by info server
and show you how it works and why it is
so easy for anyone to use
i mean even students ban without a
background in bioinformatics
and computational i mean in
computational sciences can do this so
this is the tibia info server
and once you register we will be sharing
uh
the access for you to take some of the
example pipelines from here
and now let me show you an example
pipeline from the transcriptomics data
analysis
so it's an ai guided uh platform and we
have put together examples from
publications
that you can take and learn from and at
the same time you
learn about the logic so many of these
algorithms that you see here
are open source algorithms so our
purpose is not to
make you dependent on a platform for
data analysis but
make it simple so that you understand
how the algorithms are used
what are the outcome what are the
outputs that you get from this sort of
analysis
and how to interpret that result so
understand the logic
behind the analysis is what we are
focused on that's why we are called umix
logic
and uh to do this i mean we have put
together many examples for you to go
through
one of the examples that i'm taking you
through is the cell line data set
so it's a rna-seq experiment where the
scientists
or the researchers have generated data
on
cell line using cell line breast cancer
cell line
samples and then we are processing the
raw data here
using these pipelines so we have already
put together
different sections for different sort of
analysis for example
pre-processing mapping quantification
these are different
um sections that you have to
go through to process data and get a
structured table and now
one thing that you can see is that they
are differently colored
so to make it more easy and simple they
are color coded so that you understand
that
these sections are used for
pre-processing these sections are used
for mapping
this is for quantification of expression
level and what are all
of these steps and we will be going
through in detail in other in the
workshop session
and also they are described i mean
absolutely amazingly in the courses
that you will have access and you will
have go through you'll have
the opportunity to go through in this
training so
uh the input file and the output file
are already stored because the example
pipeline for you to learn
so the first step that we do in such
analysis is to
clean the data make it more structured
so we use
uh algorithms such as dramatic pcr clean
and then i'm going to show you how we
can map it to the transcriptome
and then generate a table of expression
so if you can see i i should be a little
slow i know
but uh it's a quick demonstration and
we'll be going through this
in much more detail in the session and
it's described in the courses as well
but here also you will be able to learn
about these
these pipelines these algorithms what
they do
what paper that you can read about them
also and learn about them in much more
detail
so here uh what we did is that we
pre-processed the data
we mapped it to a transcriptome and we
when we
say if we are mapping or aligning it to
a transcriptome
we are doing it on a reference
transcript term and then we are
generating a table of expression after
doing the
uh alignment or the comparison and then
we are doing ending the pipeline
and here you will see that there are
different courses that you can take
and go through uh which are on the learn
portal now
uh during the session we will be able to
tell you the
output and how to exp how to uh you know
analyze
these results and what is the outcome
and what can you do
next so the next step is to take this
data structure table
run some uh other analysis and do some
machine learning analysis based on the
research that we are looking going
through so
this is the way we uh kind of go and
explore the tiva info platform
and obviously it has also the capability
to
to do the analysis right from ncbi so
you can upload data from ncbi
you can upload data from your own
research lab and those
are available with different
subscription options
to access this platform with the program
you will be able to use it for
educational purpose you can be
you'll be able to do example pipelines
and learn first
before you do your own experiments so
that's the process that we follow
for you to go through the technology uh
first
go through the steps uh do the data
analysis on example projects
and then learn on your own or public
data that is available
and that we discussed that it's it's so
huge that we have been able to do
a lot of quality research out of that
data so this is about the tbi info
platform that you will have access to
and this is this is the coursework for
genomics and then we have the coursework
for
uh metagenomics it's very elaborated
coursework
as as i was telling you there are
examples here that you can learn from
and learn about the otus learn about
different types of meta genomic analysis
learn about the data to pipeline file
seek all of this
is compare is covered in different
tutorials under this section so if you
go to the course
for metagenomics you will find all of
them bundled together that you can take
one by one
and learn about and apply this to your
own research once you've been able to
do go through this material which is
mostly hands-on
and also gives an overview of all the
technology and there are also videos in
the tutorials
so you will be able to go through the
videos recorded videos
and replicate that using the t-band for
platform
because at the same time you will have
an access to do this hands-on thing
so that's why the so mixed logic
training is a really unique opportunity
to learn uh for real so the next uh
technology that we will be covering is
the transcriptomics technology
and we have detailed explanation of this
transcript of
transcriptomics data analysis we've been
doing
several programs and uh have a lot of
participants who have gone through this
uh training and come up with unique
projects that have been published
as well as uh got recognition in various
conferences
and presentations so uh another aspect
of doing
uh an advanced level analysis is to
learn about
uh the application of machine learning
and uh
we use different type of machine
learning regression uh
so their effect factor regression
analysis supervised machine learning
unsupervised machine learning uh kind of
get insights and results from
transcriptomics data analysis
another advanced section that is again
available
i mean uh as i said it's a
subscription-based model if you are
into this then you can go in deep into
this and
maybe you know try different courses run
some
ideas that share with us some research
ideas that we can work on
so there are different ways we can
collaborate and do research together
so singles and transcriptomics is such a
area very promising area
a lot of modern research and high
value research is coming out of high
impact research is coming out of single
cell analysis
and there's a lot of data that has been
deposited as well
so uh another uh aspect of doing this
all of this
is to learn machine learning how you can
apply machine learning bioml
that that is also is in there in the
course work
so you will also have opportunity i know
that there is a lot of coursework that
you can do and learn from
so you can also take your time and go
through this analysis at your own pace
and at the same time learn from the
video that will be recorded and provided
to you
and we will have also mentors that you
can you know connect with
and learn about specific sort of
analysis
all those opportunities uh are available
uh
on with us for this mixed logic training
so um that is about the course work that
is there
uh other than that i have already told
you about the data science part
uh for r and python and then we have uh
mentors uh that and then we have
programs
and which uh which which i can show you
actually quickly
here on the website uh so
when when you're logged in you have
option to do
course work you have option to select a
program and you have option to do
research
so we believe that it's best to start
with the coursework go through the
examples
and then conduct your own research and
learn from specialization programs
one of such program is this one that is
omics logic bioinformatics and
computational biology
people interested in infectious diseases
data science
transcriptomics we have specialization
programs that we keep on doing
as well for those but uh to those who
have
just started this is a best opportunity
for you to take
omislogic bioinformatics uh and
computational biology
so that was about uh my presentation and
i hope that
you were able to understand what i have
covered
and what we have covered and talked
today and
if there are any questions i'll be happy
to take those questions
and at the same time it would be
great for you to ask them right now
and then i would like to maybe
invite uh our ceo ilia brodsky
to tell you a little bit more about
research and the opportunities
uh with research that we have we have a
symposium coming up
uh in on august 21st and 22nd where we
will be showcasing
all of this research that our interns
are doing and then there will be
opportunities to
uh you know talk uh talk about your own
research
as well so over to you yeah
yes thank you very much mohit and
welcome everyone
great to see all of you here i will just
briefly introduce the symposium
uh just kind of starting off with why
this is the right time so
as mohita has already mentioned there
have been numerous breakthroughs in
molecular biology
including advances of precision medicine
biotechnology agriculture
all of these have translated into
advanced technologies that actually
simplify generation of accurate and
in-depth data
but the lack of analytical power and
appropriate skills
creates a huge gap between data
and the bioinformatics and the
information that is needed
in many of these fields so there's
actually a gap
between the lab and people who make
decisions and so
to bridge this gap we started looking
into some information from
people who are involved in this kind of
in these kinds of tasks and
the survey clearly shows that the
majority
of users that are attempting to run
pipelines and analyze
large-scale high-throughput omics data
are struggling
with the data analysis component and so
we understood that there has to be a
solution
that is designed for early on
while there are students in high schools
colleges and universities
to actually supplement their educational
curriculum that they already have
introducing them to these challenges
early on and building a pipeline for
them to develop
research skills and practices in
applying their
in applying bioinformatics analysis
tools to large-scale
data sets and actually developing
research projects to showcase what they
have learned so
not a skill based on a certificate based
course but
a research experience and so to
introduce how
this could be done and discuss some of
the challenges that
exist in this field of bioinformatics
and data science for life science data
we are going to hold this omics research
symposium
which is going to be dedicated to the
future of bioinformatics education
and will cover critical challenges and
we hope to identify solutions
for improved educational strategies that
are focused on biology
as a data science and we have a great
panel of speakers that are experts
who will be addressing the pressing
challenges with data science education
for all life sciences students
and explore how to best equip all life
science students in data skills for the
21st century
our speakers will bring their
perspective as researchers working on
cutting-edge topics in bioinformatics
they are directors of successful degree
programs
and who are seeing their students
continue with successful careers in
education
academic research and industry and
together they will kind of provide us
with a comprehensive view of both the
opportunities for students
and the challenges to be addressed and
hopefully make the most out of their
studies and focus on acquiring the
skills that matter
and that will really help them become
successful and make a true difference in
these emerging fields of biotechnology
precision medicine
bioinformatics data science and others
so
what we will discuss in the symposium is
number one
for students how do you stand out from
the crowd when you apply for academic
programs or careers in bioinformatics
number two for universities how can
universities uh
equip their students with relevant
skills and experiences
providing them with an opportunity to
stand out
and then we will also discuss the future
of this field of bioinformatics as a
whole
how it's changing it's changed
dramatically over the past 10 years
at least and where we can find these
cutting edge challenges that
someone can contribute to and these
include you know you can probably think
of them
yourself crispr technologies right
revolutionize genomic engineering
uh we have genomic sequencing that is
under 1 000
for the whole genome so the sequencing
technologies have been changed
dramatically
we can also see the application of
machine learning and ai
deep fold recently released right so we
all hear about that
and obviously mrna vaccine so the
translation from
research to application has been
tremendously sped up
already drug discovery drug repurposing
all of these challenges have
been undergoing a dramatic change and so
to participate in this revolution
utilizing data science what our
interest and our goal is is to identify
effective practices
that allow students to participate
in these challenges and the way that
they can do it is by learning first
about the challenges
understanding the tools just like you
are listening today to this program
and then applying them and applying them
means developing research
uh projects and so here we will also
showcase
student projects that have been
completed over this summer in the past
several months
we have hundreds of students working on
these kinds of research projects and
through the same portal that you've
already registered in you will be able
to see
how this happens those will be
evaluated by our team of mentors and
judges
with expertise in bioinformatics
medicine
microbiology biotechnology and others
we will also highlight some of the
exciting
updates to the tbi info platform the
platform covers many different types of
bioinformatics applications
but it also includes some new sections
that are going to be presented
by the team at the talbot bioinformatics
research center and those include
technologies for single cell genomics
and multi-omics integration
uh advanced mathematical modeling for
different processes related to the field
of virology
ultra deep sequencing technologies and
the integration of multi-omics data
we will also share some exciting updates
about the onyx logic training modules
for biology as a data science
and we will discuss some of the regional
collaborations that we have
in the united states india and africa
highlighting important modules that
could be applied
to oncology infectious diseases
neuroscience and agriculture
we will introduce new modules and
project examples from precision medicine
as a pre-clinical and clinical training
option we will discuss how this pandemic
gave public awareness about infectious
diseases
and what kinds of hands-on exercises
students can access to
to learn about the viral bacterial and
parasite-caused infections
using largely available public domain
data
we will discuss advances in agriculture
and the rise of technology driven
precision agro technology with a focus
on sustainable food supply
climate resistant strain reading and
methods of bioinformatics analysis that
are in high demand
in this industry and what areas of
research are
in pressing needs finally we will
introduce
our new and planned specializations like
the field of astrobiology
that is captivating the minds of
students who are seeing the commercial
space industry
take off and develop before their eyes
so together with our existing modules
for which you will gain access so you
already
have register and you will have access
to the basic modules
you will explore them including all the
different exercises that have been
already mentioned so
importantly what we will offer for
students who are joining is also some
exciting opportunities
to join academic programs so if you are
considering education and bioinformatics
formal education and bioinformatics
there are many different universities
that offer
such programs but they're not the same
in every
single program so every program has a
perspective and a focus
and a special kind of you know variation
to
the curriculum and the objectives and so
we will bring directors of these
programs to share
how their program is different what is
the program
kind of focused on and specialized in
and how a student can join and we will
have presenters from carnegie mellon
university
louisiana state university health
sciences center
in new orleans georgetown university
systems medicine program
amity university university of ghana and
others
and the objective here is really to
offer opportunities for students who are
entering this field or who are already
in this field from
data generation from bioinformatics
analysis and integration and
all the way to decision making to really
provide them with a comprehensive
bioinformatics training in biology as a
data science so
you can register for free just to attend
uh if someone could please post the link
in the chat box
on how to register uh if you
uh register and you have a project
that you would like to present to our
judges
and evaluators you can also submit
a poster and that poster could be either
just
presented or it could be showcased if it
wins a prize
we have cash prizes that
best posters will receive
in the different categories that we have
and importantly you will get recognition
from many different respected
universities and research centers
that are going to be there and
represented
we will also have companies those
companies will be talking a little bit
about
how they are providing opportunities for
people who are starting their careers
students and recent graduates to get
into internships
and various opportunities to start their
career with
biotechnology utilizing bioinformatics
and data science
so i'm excited about this again this is
august
21 to 22. uh thank you mohit for sharing
the link
so the link is in the chat you will see
here
that you can simply submit this form to
participate
and learn a little bit more about the
different people who are involved what
are the different topics you can submit
your
research poster if you're interested and
also look a little bit into
what else we are going to be doing and
here at the bottom you will find a video
presentation
and of course we are all excited to join
this and not only
to learn about these pressing challenges
but we also want to
get to know all of you the community
that we interact with regularly
to learn more about what you are doing
and we also have some
hiring ongoing so we're hiring students
and researchers as well so we are
looking to connect with you uh there as
well
thank you everyone that's all i had to
share
so back over to you my fursona
thank you india uh i think if there are
any questions
we can answer those and uh then we can
conclude the sessions
maybe we could just also mention our
social media groups where people can
join
and we can learn about them more there
as well
yes so let me quickly share that
with you
thank you sunadika for posting the
channel link
so you can join our uh linkedin channels
where we keep on posting about the job
opportunities
and you can also learn about what is
the research which is going on and what
are the programs that we are doing and
the events that we keep on
posting about in you by joining these
groups
you can also join us on facebook uh
using
the link here one second please
subscribe you can also share this
facebook
link
sure sir i would be doing that uh just
in a second
so being a part of our linkedin group
will also help you
get in touch with a lot of researchers
and know about what's going on around
and also stay updated with all our
programs and courses i'm sharing the
link to our facebook page
and also we have a telegram group and
whatsapp group so that you can stay in
touch with us
and also a slack channel to for better
communication
i can share the links as well and also
uh if you have any queries regarding the
program i would be sharing the
program uh registration link once again
with you
all and if you have any queries you can
mail me at marketing at the
pine dot bio or support at the eight
pine dot bio
let me just quickly put it in the chat
box